And, of course, there's going to be more challenging quizzes here,
but for a warmup I think it is very good to understand the difference
between computability and complexity theory.
The first question, how fast a computer can find a way between 2 points on a map,
belongs in complexity theory because here it's a question of resources.
So "how fast," that is a question about the time that a computer needs,
and therefore, investigating this question belongs in complexity theory.
Asking if a program can decide if another program is malware,
that belongs in computability because we are not asking
about any resources, we're just if it's possible in principle.
We're asking, "Can a program do that?"
We're not asking how fast or with how much memory it can do that.
In the third question we are, again, asking about resources.
We're asking about how much memory, and therefore, this 1 belongs in complexity theory.
The question about memory is something we are not going to look at much in this course.
Actually, I think we are not going to look at it at all.
We're going to be concerned mostly with time, how fast a computer can solve a given problem,
and, toward the end of this unit, we are going to pose the ultimate resource question
and ask, "What are the limits of computation in general?